niger's co-leaders have met with the new
interim government that comes as
tensions are escalating between the
Hunter and neighboring countries a
21-member cabinet was named hours before
leaders of the West African block ecowas
met on Thursday the group announced a
standby Force which could intervene in
the country if the military continued
their hold on power thousands of coup
supporters rallied against the decision
in Naomi on Friday well Lambert Idris
joins us now from GPR on the border
between Niger and Nigerian of course
tensions are increasing
Emmett with Niger and its neighbors
what's the situation like where you are
as this news filters through
it's it's a it's a tense situation for
many people here uh if I step out of the
picture for example this is the boundary
between Nigeria and Niger this used to
be a very vibrant trade route between
Nigeria and Nigeria on a daily basis
officials here are telling us that
hundreds of cars across this point to go
into uh to come into Nigeria to take
supplies and cross over Indonesia and
some goods and passengers cross over
from Nigeria into Nigeria into Nigeria
now we spoke with an official high
official senior official here in katsina
state which is the state bordering Asia
Republic and he told us that because of
the concern of a possible airstrike some
Nigerians have moved inside katzina
State this is an area that shares
cultural and religious Affinity with the
people in Nigeria here so a lot of
people are worried that in case of
airstrike there will be a lot of
problems a lot of refugees will come
into this area and there will be we are
problems with security as well so it's a
tense situation at the moment and of
course we step to the market we went to
the market just a short while ago and we
realized that the prices of Commodities
have just gone beyond the reach of an
ordinary Nigerian I mean energy I've
touched on the fact of the sort of
connectivity between the two countries
certainly in terms of trade but there
was a great deal of people-to-people
contact here communities talk to each
other there's intermarriage
interrelationships and into family
connections here this is a problem that
could be exacerbated if the borders
remain closed or if I should say the
political tension continues to increase
exactly and that's already happening
we've noticed that already and officials
in the northern part of Nigeria that
shares common boundaries with a Nigeria
Republic are trying to douse tension
unfortunately the rhetoric coming from
Miami from the military Junta is not
helping and that is whipping up
sentiments against Nigeria against
Nigerian Nigerians because they feel
that the president of Nigeria leads the
Echoes and they see echoes in the
president of Nigeria so it's becoming
more and more complicated but again when
you speak to a lot of people they don't
believe that fighting will take will
take place or will destroy centuries all
Traditions between the two people but
with Echoes ramping up the rhetoric and
also ramping up measures about security
and possible Invasion uh people in
Nigeria are still concerned that yes
airstrikes and possible Invasion may
happen so it's a it's a huge problem and
uh we we're noticing that a lot of
people are really really worried about
things developing this way here in
katsina state and across other states
seven states by the way in the north of
the country share common boundaries
Indonesia Republic and that's why when
President Bola achinivo went to the
Senate seeking for its approval uh for
to launch to send Nigeria's troops to
Tunisia as part of ecow's intervention
Force there was total rejection from
northern Senators who formed part of the
uh who come from this section that
borders Nigeria and Nigeria of course
we'll continue to monitor what goes on
in those border areas for the moment
Emily dressed in jibia thank you